we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p here's an
interesting little voice mail that came
in you guys should include your middle
initials on the new bar that tells your
guys's name i mean if it was like David
seed Pakman or david w pacman or Patrick
c42 Patrick W Ford you guys would look
so professional yeah no idea so what the
caller is referring to is on the video
version of the show we've got some great
new graphics that were designed by
Jeremy paczynski a longtime viewers of
the show and they're very cool graphics
and what the caller is pointing out is
that neither of our little graphics with
our names have our middle initials I
don't have a middle initial that's why
there's no middle initial that could be
there I'm going to keep my note middle
initial secret I mean is that it caused
me a lot of teasing over the years I'm
just going to keep it under wraps oh oh
I do not want to look at reddit in about
three hours because the latest Pat we've
got Kira gate involving Pat and a whole
host of other scanned or just going to
keep the secret if you don't want to say
I mean you don't even have to say it but
I don't know all right it's got a little
awkward here we're gonna have to talk
about this later on the bonus show today
us psychologists claim that social media
use increases loneliness an Austin man
has been arrested for having sex with a
fence what are the logistics of that and
a massive Mexico us raw sewage spill is
under investigation there's sort of a
lot of political implications there as
well get instant access to the bonus
show by being a member sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership membership
is the number one and primary funding
source for this program we do have a
coupon code available I voted 17 it'll
give you a tremendous discount off of
membership